reject nation we got ourselves the next
episode of superman and lois i
appreciate everyone who's joining us on
this journey if you can leave a like
that would be the most helpful at this
moment and time to subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction is up for this
series full length watch the long street
stick with the time code for superman
lewis will burn our patreon page special
thing so i'll become super adjustable
check out all we have to offer over
there so thanks to the boys that prepper
for episodes
[Music]
previously on superman and lois
you're the opposite of me
i don't remember any of this i remember
nothing about my recent life but this
[Music]
i love zack snyder
get that cape flapping
oh my god are we getting like a bizarro
origin story we're on the other side i
think
super asthma
oh no
it's like the old boy fight
who's superman
oh that's a twist
punch our head off
gotcha gotcha pour right through the
center of his own earth and now i'm
stuck once again
because of you not because of me because
you killed innocent people two teenagers
only by necessity you almost killed my
friend he attacked me you tried to kill
me because i needed those visions to
stop oh
all that matters is the pendant is
destroyed why didn't you i was unable to
i don't possess enough strength on this
earth the yellow sun weakens me
find the pendant and see it destroyed
and if she does
merge
what would happen
she would inherit enough power
to send us all into oblivion
what would be the point of that the cool
ass intro well maybe there's another
reason he wants the pendant destroyed
but it seems consistent with ali's
teachings
[Music]
this is the last verified location we
have that's enough and our superman he's
still hesitant to share information with
me i'm beginning to understand why ma'am
over 20 years sam lane never had a
single problem with superman not one
you've been here for six months not
one you will find that pale son of a
[ __ ] by any means necessary or you will
be stripped of your duties
yes ma'am
um hard castle more like hard ass
what's this that's uh candace is
actually
she's got asthma you know she's probably
left in my bag to be honest
to be honest
super deduction powers jordan you're
starting tonight that's amazing honey
yeah well timmy's sick so it doesn't
matter how it happened jordan what
matters is
what your brother does with this
opportunity your mom's right now's your
chance to show coach and everybody what
you can do definitely this opportunity
comes once in a lifetime jonathan steady
here for coming home again
i don't know sweets
but i do know
that your father loves you very much
both of you
honey can you uh please help your sister
get dressed i need to cry for a minute
hey you just missed clark and the boys
that was intentional actually
thought it'd be better if only you were
here right now
why
so the three of us can talk
what
[Music]
oh boy
lane family reunion
i don't know why she makes me laugh
why are you even here do you think i
would come here on my own i think it's
time for both of you to apologize no
this is not a both side situation she
blackmailed me this coming from the
world's shadiest journalists girls
please oh my god
you girls
are my
world and it breaks my heart to see you
at each other's throats it's bizarre i'm
so sorry for your loss
jesse wanted to be a hero
just like you oh
this is your fault
mr commanding officer i take full
responsibility for what happened
where is the monster that killed my
daughter
[Laughter]
now you have my word i will not rest
until i oh boy your promises are what
got my daughter killed
you are a disgrace
man the women hate anderson
that thing that killed him is still out
there and it is up to you and me to stop
it
we speaking private
away from all these dead bodies man what
would happen if jordan took xk too much
problems
you mean after the world's worst
quinceanera
yeah it wasn't that bad
it's like he tricked us into believing
he was this good guy all the way out
he's banging some random bartender
oh no what
bartender's my mom she's not red
she has a life
i was wrong and there's no excuse in
what i did but i need you to know that i
love you how long did it last six months
oh that's a long time
i made a horrible mistake but i am so
much stronger now
we you and me we're so much stronger now
so it's a good thing it happened
dad's not really familiar with any movie
not named delta force just saying well
you two have a chuckle at my expense i
have some business to attend to that
excuse doesn't really work when you're
retired
i'll be right outside peanut
now that they've left
everything's better
but first i need to destroy the pendant
i'll run it up the chain of command
[Music]
what i have to go
sergeant
find out where he's going
i don't trust that anderson guy one bit
oh he's gonna get desperate and do
something shady
cool
dude cold breath coming in handy this
season
hi it's me clark oh my god he's exactly
the same hasn't been that long what a
dweeb
i think she's been here all day all day
yeah it's been nice i don't trust her
russia
stopped an avalanche from destroying a
small village
he is never going to tell me the things
that i need to know
destroy that village
yes anderson [ __ ] knew it i think i
know how to bring this rogue kryptonian
into our custody
but i'm going to need your permission to
do it why would you talk to him clark do
you think that you would stay with lois
if she cheated on you i guess it depends
on what actually happened
i need to know the details of the
situation first and then
make a decision from there
to laser her head off or not
what would be the details you would need
about your wife cheating on you well you
know maybe it's all his fault or
something and he didn't know
hypothetically speaking you got to meet
your bizarro self lana what can i get
you
or her
yeah i'm not here for a drink
bring it in gross
bring it in do you think he's gonna have
an optic discharge definitely and cold
breath and super hearing
jump camp yes guys you ready to wrestle
with some nasty gators yes gods you
ready to send them back to the swamp yes
guys let's get out there and kick from
[Applause]
there's a lot of positive energy
hey nothing bad gonna happen today
just do what got you here
wrestle take care of itself
thanks though
i'm just gonna hit the bathroom before
the game right
[Music]
yeah let's do it in public
[Music]
good throw
kid's got my arm here we go true i set
two state records my senior year
family hey i will pull out all the stops
to impress my nephews
i think they would probably just be
happy to have aunt lucy around again i
think i'd like that too i don't trust
you what happened between me and kyle
was wrong
and i am sorry
i was stupid and naive
did you love him
yeah oh
kyle's a good guy
when it came down to it he did the right
thing in joseph's family
he even made me dress up as you when
exactly did he break things off with you
maybe two years ago
after sarah's accident
yeah ron then
thanks for speaking with me damn lana
you weren't sure you were handling this
so well i gotta say
emotional mvp
yes come ready to make the red touch
sounds yes come on let's go
very intense
what else is she capable of ally's
reputation was dragged through the mud
what other choice does she have i'm
guessing anything not involving drugging
or black man
i am just worried that you're not seeing
the bigger picture
i tried i really did but you refuse to
be wrong and i cannot be around that
lucy
tell dad i'll call him later
man yeah timmy's mom caught him huffing
some weird drug from the lines what do
you mean huffing i don't know i guess he
was using an inhaler or something
apparently all the kids and squirting
good choice of words simply rounded up
the train of command and my superiors
agreed the threat warranted immediate
action well you can tell them i'll
destroy the penalty
god damn it
what are you doing
what i have to so you finally give me
what i need
this was approved
somehow
meet me at my car after
my parked work start
perfect spot for a drug deal jonathan's
gonna let out some optic discharges
he's gonna say aren't you
who cares
ha
what can you not handle me finally
getting what i deserve no no that's not
what this is about it's always what it's
about jordan
lay off
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh my goodness oh it's like the
opening fight
okay cool interesting
you're not acting like yourself this is
the new me so you better get used to it
oh
boy
whoa
dude i'm not gonna let you do this i
said lay off
boys jordan
jordan jordan
i'm sorry
i'm sorry man
i didn't mean all that [ __ ] i meant
don't do this
i don't have another choice
i hate that guy
someone in the comments is defending him
i i know he's in a tough position
bureaucracy's hard she said you were a
good guy and that the reason you broke
it off was to save your family
that's
i mean that's right that's that that's
definitely right i think that you need
to move out
no lana please pick up your stuff in the
morning after the girls are gone just
make sure my car isn't in the driveway
uh-huh that's right call i hate to break
it to you but being a parent never gets
easier it could only be said by somebody
who didn't have to breastfeed at 3am too
much information or change twins diapers
when they both pooped at the same time
too much information now i messed up and
it's not gonna happen again okay
whatever man how'd you find out
timmy's mom found an inhaler apparently
the police are involved
maybe you should quit man not yet it's
clark
he's been arrested for treason
oh what a crock of [ __ ] wow
what a crock of [ __ ]
and they made it coffee shaped lovely
i hate this guy so much
until he reveals the location of that
thing that killed our men superman will
remain a prisoner of the united states
government
are they taking him sir to be with his
brother
[Laughter]
wow good call cheese
it's always too soon when the credits
roll i thought we were going to get like
uh
the way how lana showed up and
[Music]
bizarro's world mm-hmm
like that
oh it'll happen
no it won't
you're right you're the predictor
thank you you're welcome
i really appreciate it
man you got all the good theories
seriously why would he why would why
would superman trust
second he started talking with him like
this is gonna so backfire yeah
unfortunately he's just backed into too
much of a corner
it's [ __ ] yeah
although now i i feel like they're gonna
do a second half of the season reversal
on him or something
addison's gonna be the big hero that's
right they'll find some begrudging
reason to trust each other eventually
i think lawn is a total hypocrite
definitely
i mean
jordan she was like
he doesn't deserve you if he can't
forgive you
and now lana just can't forgive kyle
it's the exact exact
same thing in 100 percent one-to-one
comparison totally ma'am
like this season's supposed to be about
forgiving cheaters
[Music]
and
you know what uh
i'm on kyle's side because
lana
you are
totally not setting a good example
you're not leading by example for your
daughter
and sarah getting
her dad
when sarah's a cheater that's right
well i mean alex looks like she just
can't stand looking at her own
reflection one two one
comparison oh yeah i mean it really just
highlights the clear mistake kyle made
which was not having an affair with
somebody of the same sex as him then
this would all be so easy
yes
yes it would
like this like the sarah thing
anyway
i'm not going to clarify anything
good still both on that note yes that's
the review
so one to one
and uh hey and we beat it
comment below why you hate lana
now these days we have to clarify when
we're being sarcastic
because no one picks up autonated words
it wasn't a problem when this channel
started but lately it's been a major
problem in our lives let's just assume
everything is sarcasm and you'll be 50
right
that's the joke it's not a one-to-one
comparison and i am a hundred percent on
the side
yeah
agreed she handled that with uh poise
despite the pain
a lot of good scenes she's trying to be
as mature as possible about it
well we definitely know her inverse
version of herself is going to show up
in this series now
i mean i already did but it'll probably
cross through the world i really love
that opening with bizarro yeah that was
really cool
the tone of that
felt like a poem yeah like a poem tone
like a tone poem
a poem of tone
super zack snyder yeah for sure yeah
yeah i mean the needle drop and the
slow-mo and just the like sort of air of
like you're floating through this
heightened fantasy and everything is
super picturesque the perfect lens
flares the cape flapping
zack snyder better that by the way
mm-hmm uh this is the first person to
fly
[Music]
uh it could have only been more zack
snyder if they started off on hallelujah
as the song
there's something interesting about that
one shot that's in the hall that seems
that it's not like the most
stylized but it's kind of cool with
watching
watching the struggle like the the
physicality of it was it's interesting
just because it's not like just crazy
choreography
you're just watching a guy like
a superman level power but
not at its
full capacity
so you're you know i don't i don't know
what i'm trying to say i just look good
well yeah he's having to fight with just
the kind of human level strength so
these guys are a bit of a challenge but
it's a testament to just how you know
good of a fighter you know hallway one
shots man this way to do it that's right
well that was an interesting bookend i
mean it makes me wonder about the i mean
i know he has that meeting with ali
and uh there's that but even beyond that
it seemed like there was an intentional
bookending of that
motif there you know and i wonder if
there's maybe more to it than
than meets the eye
at the outset but i don't know it was a
very nice yeah just kind of visual
marriage i think bizarro's inverse
timelines on a later timeline
um so his events play out
first
okay so that's kind of a foreshadowing
and this also represents a bizarro
that's right
you know she just killed try to kill her
take the pendant for himself
[Music]
instead of trying to play the nice guy
superman way
it's probably america mark it's
that's the problem with america's we're
always trying to play the nice guy
superman yeah
really we just need to go bizarro
kill the threat
occam's razor
i'm really interested to see like more
bizarro's story though for sure his
story seems interesting i like that he's
even on his world he's an outcast mm-hmm
is everyone just going to look like him
but no no he's treated like a freak
yeah i i mean i don't you know
you never know what the budget although
i feel like i mean the first season i
always heard was was produced by hbo and
it feels like the production values are
pretty uh on par with that this time
around so part of me is holding out hope
for like a a an episode that mostly
takes place on the other side um but
even just getting like his you know
journey to
our side and kind of his perspective on
that was super cool
i mean yeah you see his home's all
messed up his cat farm and his
red world he's got this cat
what is that cat the cat
cat feels like an easter egg
or it's just a [ __ ] cat
it's the flirkin
finally marvel crossover is happening
with dc hold on i gotta google it yes
yes
this is gonna be good
so hold on to your butts
hold on to your ex kryptonite superman
cat
there are uh is it streaky the super cat
let's go with streaky the super it's the
streaky the super cat streaky the super
cat appeared in action comics number 261
he is an ordinary domestic cat of the
kents
actually this sounds like it's probably
accurate
maybe streaky will cross over from the
other side and be adopted by the kents
in the real regular world i think
in the non-bizarro timeline
this is what eric boss does the new rock
stars he google stuff and then he just
acts like he knows us off the top of his
head
they should do new rock stars should do
those streaky the super cat guys
now they should do like when people do
like an editing live stream except it's
just the the research for the script
live stream where it is just him
googling stuff going on i think it could
be this
no oh well i'll work it in anyhow this
is mephisto
[Music]
it's my eric boss impression
[Music]
it's a very confident impression that's
because eric is not a confident man
my impressions cut to the core
they might not be what you see on the
surface but they are true
nah eric is uh is more confident than me
so
that's a that's an overstatement john
eric is intensely
ridiculously more confident
chrissy was not in this episode
um oh what's her other name what's the
girl's name the sister to lois lucy
lucy
lucy
seal
lucy
is annoying
i can meet you partway on that at least
i mean i i i don't think i'm not
actually like annoyed when i'm watching
her
but when you know
she uh
wait why is she all traumatized what's
going on here why is she traumatized
oh
is it the you know like oh my brother
like two sons experience a drunk dad
one's ends up an alcoholic the other
ends up
completely not wanting to drink alcohol
i mean that kind of thing that's
happening here is like these similar
experiences but you know yeah you see
younger sibling experience in this now
she's all trouble is that what's
happening probably lois became the super
attentive you know
stricter one yeah then lucy becomes the
at-risk one it's just the fact that they
have pulled back the curtain and really
shown that
um
ally is
dumb itch
makes she makes me just get like that
lie when she's like you just kidding me
well you're wrong
and i'm like come on man
you're defending a woman who drugged
people
she's just like going to bed so
so much that she's like aldi has to do
whatever ali has to do
and i get the character
she's fine
i liked their debate but yes by that
point i was like nothing no
not even like a bit of a well yes that's
extreme
or some kind of acknowledgement you have
of
the at least murkiness of her situation
like i like their yeah i like the text
of their conversation and for
how the show needed to do it i thought
it was pretty well done
but
i mean it could have been more graceful
i think she's going to die by an
onslaught of bullets
bullets bullets i mean she could die
i just imagine the scenarios
getting shot all of the times
yeah and then she'll be the big bad for
season she'll come back she'll just be
full of holes
be great
yeah
well
this was the most i bought her it was
the most real i thought she was
sometimes when she's like acting annoyed
and frustrated i don't believe her i
really believed her as an aunt
and i really believed her in the
football scene when she's arguing with
lois yeah that's really good yeah some
good just character stuff
and uh yeah it's that kind of thing
where when they're talking it gets so
good to the point where i'm like
really like none of this is gonna rub
off when you start talking like you're
just gonna like flip the switch right
back to like we're talking about ally
and everything's bad
yeah it almost felt like not talking
about ali was the key
and that made everything good well it
seems like what should have happened is
they should have also talked about ali
at some point
with the dad moderating the conversation
sure that
[ __ ] hot dogs bro
if you just hadn't gotten to go to get
those hot dogs and then come back with
the hot dogs right when the game is over
you think lana's gonna try to sleep with
clark
i just want everyone to become unlikable
she's going to go sleep with tonya
i want to know
kyle has to come in did you love lana
do you want to love you
who am i
yeah no lana she just seems like such a
downgrade of her character
tanya
yeah she's not lana man but that's
that's what affairs are like
sometimes i guess
you're like oh
i guess that's the that's the the the
sad nature people often i feel like i've
heard this a few times in life where
someone's like oh how could you how
could you cheat on this person because
they're so amazing you know and this
person's so average or something but
then again you never know what the
circumstances are
and i like that you just want something
different
sure yeah or maybe you know you strike
up a convo over pores
and hey maybe you got a few things in
common but i like the way they
articulate all the stuff in that story
especially through lana
done going going back to the non-sarcasm
at the top of the review
uh i think they've handled those those
things are elements that could get
especially
melodramatic road silly annoying etc and
uh they've done a nice job doing a
cheating related storyline twice in one
season you know
like i feel like they've been pretty
conscientious and they're good at
leaving you in a place where i'm like
that's a totally fair way to handle this
lana i you know it's up to you now
you've done
you know it's like you know where kyle
stands and now you gotta search your
soul and see if this has broken your
heart or not
you know irrevocably
uh
i just don't think clark would ever get
close to cheating on lois that's the
thing there's like no peril there for me
if anyone can get away with cheating at
superman that's right
that's right
but would the guilt let him you know
i don't think he would be able to handle
the guilt
just optic discharge it out of your
system
it's right into my hands
that's good
do online therapy you get betterhelp.com
for superman i don't know what the big
deal is man just do it
you're super mad there must be like
treats lined up
like people across the world must want
to sleep with you bro
take advantage you just flew to russia
and back come on you go into this show
wants to be modern freaking get superman
cancelled dude superman takes advantage
that's in the red light district in like
the netherlands or singapore or
something like that and he just puts on
his glasses no one recognizes him
superman should get a social media
indulges in a sex addiction he's
obviously getting so many people
messaging him dudes
are you really faster than a speeder
i'm sure whoever created you know the
creators of superman have to be very
pleased uh
with that
line because it's become the go-to
innuendo when you need a superman
innuendo
that'd be cool about a story super
superhero who gets canceled
yeah it's probably coming on the boys
season 3
it's gotta be next
and build on that deep storyline all
right guys let's recap sam lane mvp
oh yeah jordan and jonathan jordan and
jonathan being
brothers and jonathan being a drug
addict
let's take the win man
who cares how it went that's right who
cares about pride honor etc dignity you
won you won and winning is the point
michael phelps took so many steroids
you don't see any repercussions yeah
dude lance armstrong
no repercussions mark mcguire
mark wahlberg mark wahlberg mm-hmm
acting steroids
these will make you a better actor
i ran out before uncharted what do i do
because i'm just me
it's okay he'll get his prescription
refilled eventually
yeah jordan and jonathan man
the good actors i feel for them
jordan just trying to be supportive
brother
jonathan just being like come on let me
get my drugs
that's my jonathan impression it's
really good
nothing's better than my harry potter
wow
everyone just needs to shut up for a
minute
but
listen
if you made it this far
i'm on lana's side
i don't actually find
lucy annoying
i'm glad jonathan felt shame and
couldn't celebrate in the joy i feel
like he's really his lesson don't lie
about all of your opinions anderson is a
dick yeah don't know wise clark ever
trusted him
some of you guys are gonna defend that
totally okay i appreciate the actor very
much but it was super obvious the second
he started talking to him like
dude clark what are you doing this guy's
about to pull some sneaky [ __ ] over
has been a highlight
and uh cgi teeth
you leave those cgi teeth alone that's
all right yeah
and tyler
hutch heisenberg
shannon
hutch guard doing a good job playing
both characters i hope he's getting two
paychecks three paychecks
why why three clark superman and pizarro
it's always god
that's totally fair
i gotta do homework for three different
people
i got three different scripts sent to my
house i come to three different costume
fittings and rehearsals
that would be so funny
oh dude imagine an oscar isaac's moon
night paycheck
every one of these guys needs one
all right
all right it's a good episode hey guys
we're gonna do a patreon
david gandy
david i just want to say
you have
the
beautiful soothing voice of david bowie
oh you have the agility of the great
david beckham you
have such a historical knowledge like
the great david attenborough oh good
david yeah
you are uh charmingly whimsical like the
wonderful david tennant oh you're also
as musically inclined as the beautiful
david growl
and you're wonderfully nerdy like david
schwimmer
but you also got the witty proudness
prowess
david letterman
and you got a sexy body like david
hasselhoff
and his prime
yeah and you have just as edgy of a
humor as david chappelle oh yeah and
you're as weird of an artist as david
lynch and you're a wizard like david
henry
who i don't know love you david
[Music]